hi Rebecca Hera Becca
or should I say Cherie yo that actually
means goodbye we do the whole thing
again I think my eyes are closed that's
fine let's just keep going I can fix
this in post we hope you're having a
great time in England even though there
are plenty of accredited colleges here
America English breakfast English
muffins and despite your new and
exciting life we want to make sure that
you don't forget about America or us
your two best friends and little sister
I feel like I'm also a best friend we've
all been friends for years
okay Jenny Zach wanted us to make a
video where we show you all the things
you're missing back home it was a mutual
collaboration cue jacket look at that we
also enlisted your old neighbor Curtis
to make this video because he has the
camera so say hi Curtis hey hey you're
good to edit this right hey Rebecca Zach
wanted me to recreate our Saturday
afternoons in the park reading young
adult novels how would you actually just
talk to the camera like she's here
I don't know Zach because I'm not living
in a fantasy world where my best friend
since elementary school hasn't abandoned
me oh whoa oh no let's let's give you
positive keep it light just read for
this part we'll just use that as b-roll
and put a voiceover all right I'll be
good we're watching your favorite movie
Love Actually it's no surprise that we
lost you to the United Kingdom totally
Colin Firth is hotter than any American
guy we turned it up I can't hear
anything
wait are we watching this entire movie I
have somewhere to be
where I don't have to tell you
everything I mean you tell Rebecca
everything yeah how'd that work out
she's off gallivanting with Harry Potter
look-alikes why are we always talking
about Rebecca cuz we are literally
making the video for Rebecca right now
okay everybody just calm down we still
need to practice the song and
synchronize when we point
cruise cards phone Curtis hey Zack here
I just thought I'd take you on a little
tour of LA just the two of us with the
little help of my friend a skateboard
I'm not sure you know how much la misses
you but we sure do now I know used to
complain about the smog and the traffic
and living in close quarters with your
little sister but I'm sure you must miss
something or someone this is my personal
segment
I just brought Curtis in case you wanted
to snake an angle Allyson give me some
space you were never here on her long
walks you being here just obstructs the
memory and ruins the emotional impact
fine I know I'm not one and when someone
tells me to leave look I'm nothing
without my GoPro turn it off Curtis
Curtis I forgot how much I love loafie
you could see her whenever you want if
you ever came to my apartment look who I
found mr. kangaroo remember when I
bought him for loafie you gave me the
longest hug because no one else
remembered his half birthday didn't
Rebecca forget your actual birthday this
year
I mean time zones are weird dates are
always confusing I remembered although I
can't recall getting a new sort of
thank-you card sometimes I feel like you
guys just hang out with me to get to
Rebecca Oh Alison no one cares about you
not you specifically I just mean like no
one cares about anyone like love is a
myth friendship is an illusion like
Rebecca right she's doing what's right
for herself she's only looking out for
her own interests like a selfish [ __ ]
don't you dare talk about Rebecca that
way she's the only one that puts up with
your depressive self-involved bull crap
Oh bullcrap Zack really that's the best
you can do have your balls not dropped
yet thanks we're all friends here no
we're not no I'm done turn off the
camera
hi I'm Zack and this is a video apology
for Gabby and Alison I hope you feel my
sincere remorse through this webcam I
let my feelings of friendship for
Rebekah cloud my actions but deep down
you can't blame me because Rebekah is
the best I mean just think about her
hair and how it's so bouncy anyway we
shouldn't let our own issues get in the
way of what's truly important
letting Rebekah know how much we miss
her and I can't do that without her two
best friends I can't do that without my
two best friends so please accept my
Google invite and meet me at the bar
tomorrow you won't regret it
Curtis I'm done how do I turn this off
I can't believe he got you to come - oh
he's paying me really hey I'm really
sorry about all - I've been so needy
since Rebecca left and I'm you think my
paranoia is setting in and that's not
been fair to you or - okay okay it's
okay it's all good can you guys stay
still for focus I'm glad you guys could
make it did you guys have any time you
know it doesn't matter let's not place
any footage why are you sweating it's
show time
this one's for you Rebecca you and I
have been dancing to the Macarena since
we've been kids now I wanna be dancing
with you for the rest of our lives no
Zach she has a British boyfriend you
idiot Rebecca will you marry me
cut to black I think we know there
hey Rebecca Curtis here I live next door
to you for two years and Zach offered me
75 bucks to shoot this thing I'm not
gonna lie and say I miss you because you
were always pretty cold I know for a
fact these people miss you like crazy so
maybe respond to their texts call them
on the weekends basically act like a
friend also Zach's in love with you and
Alison needs therapy
Gabi could probably survive a nuclear
holocaust now please enjoy 30 seconds of
these geese on a pond and think about
your decisions oh they're so cute they
should call me Mom
you